[Applause]
happy glorious friday and what a friday
it is
it seemed like only yesterday that the
media had made a fussy over jesse
i don't like that it's being put out
there in the media that this is a
possible hate crime there are a lot of
questions in this case but i know jesse
smallett is a really really good guy i
just want justice to be served in this
case and the media has really cast so
much doubt on his story which i find so
personally offensive he's given a
detailed account an account that chicago
police have said has been consistent he
hasn't changed his story they also said
it's credible police have said that and
also that he has been very cooperative
ah
and now today it's as if there's like no
news on this guy
i hope he wasn't kidnapped by white
supremacists
maybe he went on another midnight trip
to subway and was attacked by jared
i kid he's too old for jared
what does that mean i don't know but i
didn't didn't he go to court wasn't he
found guilty it seems like one moment he
was everywhere but now he's gone like
rollerblades or a cuomo
so let's pay a visit to all of those in
the media who first reported on that
vicious racist attack and see what
they're saying now
oh that's so predictable you always come
to crickets for this stuff we knew the
smolette case was bs from the start
how about you tell that cnn lady brianna
keeler to stop eating my friends
she ate my cousin last week
shout out to will kane by the way
that was interesting he's a big fan of
will kane all right
it's true they buried the story like it
was a friend of hillary clinton
that's cause when the media loves the
news they scream it from the hilltops
but when the story exposes their bias
and idiocy they hide it like brian
kilmeade's bald spot
speaking of bald spots how did the view
handle it today
it's not you know kamala harris's fault
or joe biden's father cory booker's
fault or anybody's fault that their
natural reaction was to empathize with
somebody who we all at first thought was
a victim twitter's fault anyway
it's not their fault just a natural
reaction yeah a natural reaction if you
wanted it to be true
because you invested so much in the
notion that america is full of white
male races
but this is their mo turn the news
faucet on then magically turn it off
because the media is hoping the same
people who easily bought the smellette
hoax when they championed it won't find
it now that their own feverish fantasies
turned out to be false now i'm going to
tell you the story of smilet from the
press-eyed view when the story first
broke we were all sitting around a green
room betting how many twizzlers dana
purino could eat
400
and we were all thinking the same
thoughts
i wonder if jessica's water broke
anyway that she wasn't pregnant then
actually
we all knew smollett was lying because
the lie was too much on the nose like a
hysterical plot point from law and order
but we couldn't see it just yet because
we were too afraid of being called
racist by other people in the media even
though we knew the story was as
plausible as seeing brian stelter at
soul cycle
because what smilet concocted was the
exact kind of story the media preferred
and demanded it fit their lured
assumptions of a systemically racist
evil white america see it's not a hoax
if it reflects your own fantasies it's
like a psycho stalking a famous actress
and convincing himself the actress has
the same feelings for him to him it's
not a fantasy it really exists
and i should probably apologize to kathy
bates
unfortunately for them the media's need
for racist hate crimes it's like xanax
at the view the demand far outweighs the
supply
meanwhile some scrappy local chicago
reporters bravely chase the hoax down
rafer wiegel and rob elgis they need to
be commended wiegel actually was
criticized for going on fox news to
discuss the rapidly disintegrating hoax
and his defense fox was the only network
to ask him to come on no one else would
they were too scared that their own
narratives would collapse
but what he was doing was real
journalism no wonder the legacy media
didn't recognize it but that's the good
news about the press the bad news for
every one of those guys there are 300
don lemons
so why did the media fall for this well
you can't accept a ludicrous story like
that unless you have two elements in
place a nickel bag and a bong
i wish
actually you need to be primed for it
and then you want it to be true the
priming consists of a repetitive grim
narrative pushed by outlets like cnn in
which america is full of bigots this
false narrative was the table setting
that served up whatever race oaks would
pop up and there were lots banana peels
left outside that had to be racist
because only white people have access to
fruit
a rope at a race car garage that was
about as similar to a noose as a plate
of fettuccine
workout gear in an oakland park also
became a collection of nooses who knew
that jack lalanne was a klansman
and covered furniture became a man in a
kk robe in hood hey who hasn't made that
mistake before is that the grand wizard
or a lazy boy recliner
media primed the environment so that any
racist hysteria could become reality
smellette being the enterprising race
drifting
baiter saw this as a perfect opportunity
to enhance his career and so he did it's
what narcissistic predators do he could
have gotten away with it but his only
problem he's an idiot
he hired two black guys to play two
white guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's not only a violation of cultural
appropriation but it's just terrible
casting
that's like casting gwyneth paltrow to
play rosa parks
and who's wandering around a frigid
chicago night holding rope and bleach
angry penguins that are into bondage on
their way to clean swimming pools it
makes no sense
and perhaps the biggest improbability of
all what white bag-aheads would ever
recognize jesse smallette
[Applause]
he's asked to show his id at family
gatherings
and yet the media bought it all because
like a really bad drug dealer they were
getting high on their own supply feeding
off their own race fantasies it's as if
they could believe in anything
is the problem with your workers comp
claim is that you haven't been injured
on the job arthur knows imaginary pain
can hurt like a
burn yourself committing arson that gas
station should have warned you not to
smoke did brothers you hired to pretend
to beat you up testify it was staged
after promising not to that's an oral
contract we'll get your hoax money back
call the law firm of harris swalwell and
ship and leave the line to us
i think the apple was a bit gratuitous
but okay now the press also enjoyed
acting smarter than you because they saw
this crime coming and they should have
since they're the ones who created this
frankenstein monster so when they got
screwed by their own gullibility they
fell as silent as president biden
looking for his shoes in the fridge and
if they were wrong about this what else
did they get wrong covid immigration
letting andrew cuomo act like a
freelance massage therapist
the list is longer than a receipt from
cvs
so will the press learn a lesson from
this
don't make me laugh i have msnbc for
that
let's welcome tonight's guest she's so
sharp she's not allowed on inflatable
rafts host of sunny sunny's corner on
series xm patriot
sunny johnson
her show's on so early birds let her
have the worms fox and friends co-host
carly shipkids
he's my fourth favorite cane behind
sugar candy and co
boss and friends weekend host will kane
and her wit is drier than your grandma's
elbow in december
foxy's contributor cat tim
sonny thank you for coming dressed so
festive thank you for having me my
pleasure when this was going on i just
wanted to live inside your brain
just to know thought by thought what was
happening back in 2019
um i obviously more i don't really even
give a damn about uh jesse i care about
the media because when you go through
all the facts of the story you ask
yourself how could anybody believe this
what were your thoughts during this i'm
glad that if you were a part of black
america not the media not don lemon
because for some reason it's like if joy
reid or don lemon says something that
it's automatically black people feel
that way no it's not that is not the
case if you want to know how black
people feel then go ask dave chappelle
yeah so when dave chappelle started
talking about juicy yeah that's how we
were feeling right that's where we were
at we were laughing we were ridiculing
we were having fun and i think that that
where when you talk about like cancer
culture and how people are afraid to
talk to speak up black men were not
afraid to speak up black men were
calling this for what it was at the
beginning and because they were they
were called uh sex i mean homophobic
they were they were toxic masculinity it
was it was something wrong with black
men for laughing at what they obviously
knew was a damn joke yeah so like please
if just we got to a point where you
realize that joy reid and don lemon does
not speak for us yeah then i think we
could actually have better conversations
because nobody looked at this like
racism we all looked at this as
imbecilic nonsense yeah we spent very
very little time focusing on it yes we
came back to it today to laugh again and
then we left you know like it is not as
big of an issue for us as don lemon and
joy reid would have you thank you so
true and so now this is going to lead me
into a
sexist question cats perfect all right
sonny brought up the point about the men
versus women and when i was watching the
clips
it was only women only women that were
defending this you couldn't find a male
clip even don lemon was like a little
hedgy well he was for it and then he was
kind of like until jesse threw him under
the bus exactly he threw him under the
bus then he got mad yeah you know
actually there's two white mega
supporters who threw him under the bus
is that a sexist comment cat
[Laughter]
they were probably all in their periods
right greg
they could never be president
well i agree with you on that
oh yeah women can never be president
because they're beyond their periods no
i'm being sarcastic
crazy lady i don't know i didn't take it
that way okay
what is your um what is your take on the
media look look i don't know women i i
don't know women i don't know anything
about women even though i am one
but my take on the media i think
is obviously
this would be a great story where
they'll be able to you know all of their
notions that they already have their
takes that they already have they could
just kind of insert it in like what are
those things called with the madness
it was like a mad lib where they could
just insert it as a mad lib which and
people they pump each other up right so
i think it's less about actually
thinking about could this have really
happened this way or like
why would this
person who's a tv star be getting his
own subway and why
why would he need subway that bad
they're not thinking about that they're
thinking about you know the views and
the clicks and how to and then they try
to one-up each other and how hard
they'll take it yeah yeah the subway
thing was interesting you know
he can't afford uber eats like
yeah i don't know
all right will you you're in the media i
am just like i am you look great by the
way thank you yeah i can say that
you agree with me it's the women who
fell for this right i'm joking a sexist
would say what do you make of the media
response
you know um i think you nailed it as
long as we're trading compliments in
your monologue thank you thank you nice
you made an ok sign did you see that
oh i did oh no
i'd love to blur it out
i truly think it's all about narcissism
while you couldn't find perhaps male
clips in the media you could find male
politicians you could find none other
than joe biden and so what i think is
going on is all about narcissism and we
talk about this concept of virtue
signaling so much i think the media is
full of insecure people looking for
external validation and they cast
narratives stories at all times and they
cast themselves as the heroes of these
stories i am the virtuous character i'm
sitting on the set of good morning
america denouncing racism i am a good
person filling this empty hole inside of
myself with a microphone i think that's
a lot of what's going on and they have
to keep looking for these stories as you
point out
if it's not jesse smollett it's bubba
wallace whatever it may be to continue
to be the [ __ ] the hero of this story
yeah i think and also i i have to say uh
carly that it's like all all jesse saw
was like like a trend that he could
profit off of it wasn't his fault right
he was just looking at what the media
wanted so a couple things first uh not a
sexist comment by you uh because
i i'll be perfectly honest when i
remember when i got the news alert on my
phone that said justin smallett hate
crime the whole first of all i said
who's jesse smallett i didn't know who
he was and then i i mean i believed it
because
i don't think anybody would ever think
that you would stage a hate crime
against yourself
and that's on that's on him right he's
the one that deserves the most criticism
here um but then when
the news started coming out about the
details and people started to defend him
that's when it got political and icky
you know and then there are so many
other things about this um whole
trial like the kim fox
where she was gonna drop she dropped the
charges yes and that's why i think he
did think that he could get away with it
because he has been probably coddled his
whole life while he took the stand
because he just thought that he could
get away with it because he has before
yeah exactly well we'll see what happens
next he's going to appeal it and he
thinks he's going to get off but uh who
knows we're going to get the uh the
brothers on though
one just for workout tips
just for workout tips hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else